- Vote for me.
Vote for cute and adorable Grover.
I am pro-ABCs
and for one, two, threes.
Plus I promise I have no
skeletons in my closet.
I do not even have one in my body.
- Hey, Grover, what are you doing?
- Oh, hello there, Sal Khan.
I am just running for president
of the United States of America.
I heard there was an upcoming election,
so I figured,
ah, why not?
- Well, that's great, Grover.
- Yeah!
- Maybe we can help more people vote.
- Oh, that would be terrific.
So exactly how many
votes do I need to win?
- Well, you know about the
electoral college, right?
- Of course, Sal, baby.
- I know exactly what the electrical--
- Electoral.
- Electoral college is.
- Great, so why don't
we explain it together
for those who don't know?
- Oh, why certainly.
What a brilliant idea.
- Umm.
Why don't you start us off?
- Sure.
In a direct democracy, I as a citizen
will vote for a candidate.
And whichever candidate
has the most popular votes
in the country, they
will become president.
But we do not have a direct democracy.
We have an indirect democracy.
So what happens is, is I vote in my state.
I live in California.
And whichever candidate gets
the most votes in California
will get all of California's
55 electoral votes.
And that's true in most states.
Whoever gets the most votes in that state
gets all of the votes for that state.
And that number comes from
the number of Congresspeople
California has.
- Um, dah, I am not following you.
- So how can I explain it in a way
that you might understand?
- Chickens.
(chickens clucking)
I know chickens.
Chickens, they are my biggest demo.
(chickens clucking)
- OK, chickens.
So instead of electors,
we'll say chickens.
Instead of the electoral college,
I'll say chicken college.
- OK, that I can follow.
- OK.
The number of chicken votes for each state
is equal to the number of
Congresspeople for that state.
- [Grover] In every state?
(chicken clucks)
- [Sal] Yes, Grover.
- From California to the New York island?
From the redwood forest
to the Gulf Stream waters.
- Yes.
The 50 states.
(Grover laughs)
And so there are a total
of 538 chicken votes
in the chicken college.
For example, Florida has 29 chicken votes.
(chicken clucks)
And that's the same as the 29
Congresspeople that they have,
two senators and 27 representatives.
- [Grover] Oh, hello there, chickens.
(chickens clucking)
OK, then, so how do I, candidate Grover,
win the presidency?
- Well, since there are
538 chicken votes in total,
you just have to get
more than half of those.
- More than half.
Hmm, let me see here.
(trumpets play line from
"Stars and Stripes Forever")
One, carry the two, divided by eight.
- Grover, we, we know the actual number.
You just have to get at
least 270 chicken votes
in the chicken college.
- Just 270 chickens?
I could do that.
300 chickens just crossed
the road to hear me
speak at the rally.
(chickens clucking)
- Oh, great,
do you have your speech?
- Oh, yeah, it's just right here, yeah.
Where did I put it, it?
Ah, I'll just wing it.
Bye, Sal.
- Bye, Grover.
Now get out there and vote.
(chickens cluck)
(violins play "Hail to the Chief")